i live in palo alto california and it's
a bizarre thing i think for people here
to build things physical things uh most
folks are doing dot coms
it's kind of neverland in palo alto and
so anything is possible my name is chris
robinson and for four or five years i've
been working on building the tsunami
ball it's designed to survive an inland
tsunami
march 2011
there was an earthquake off the shore of
sendai in japan which caused a tsunami
to
basically smash against
the eastern seaboard when the tsunami
happened i was at this incubator in
mountain view and i was watching live
footage of people trying to escape and
the entire office just starts discussing
how they would fix that or solve that
and i
decided then well you could very simply
just put them in like a ping pong ball
right like a sphere is a very strong
shape and so you could usher your family
into and they would float around and
they would be safe
and so i started just kind of modifying
the designs and at some point i just
extruded the shape a bit and now it's a
capsule
almost everything i'm doing here is
brand new to me i made mistakes from day
one and this was this piece that i
custom designed to be super strong and
it's massively thick right it's four
inches thick but yeah it twisted and
just snapped in half
so this is what happened when the boat
fell on me you just hope that you
survived the mistakes long enough so
that you can make progress
and then you you can
learn
[Music]
the idea is that we'll have electric
motors uh solar panels on the outside
and batteries and you'll be able to
navigate from the boat so it's not going
to be a speed boat but you'd be able to
navigate your way wherever you need to
go back to shore or help somebody else
that needs help
so we kind of share the same ideas about
how to evaluate someone's project and
it's usually based on intelligence or
money time and on those three things
this is the dumbest project you could
ever do
and so i just think of it as an
adventure i'm excited every day that i'm
out here working on it the importance is
just just building it
you